a jumble of different charges in a top
drawer many homes have them and it's a
waste the eu wants to clean up the eu
commission is proposing common usbc
charging ports for all new smartphones
ipads tablets cameras and headphones
in terms of waste this is significant
because this measure will allow us to
save 1 000 tonnes of electronic waste
and 2 600 tons of raw materials per year
there is also the impact on co2
emissions it will save 180 000 tons of
co2 equivalent per year
currently 29 of all new devices come
with the usbc cable the usb micro be
sold with android devices accounts for
50 of all charges sold while the apple
lightning port accounts for the
remaining 21
the idea to streamline all charges is
very popular with consumers the typical
person in the eu currently owns three
different charges but only uses two of
them regularly the proposal fits well
with the eu's current drive towards
sustainability and promises to save
consumers 293 million dollars a year in
unnecessary purchases
the second part of the proposal is that
new charges aren't automatically sold in
the same box with new electronic devices
but bought separately and that the
charging speed of cables is standardized
and move environmentalists are welcoming
when it's wasted you know the there's a
lot of toxic substances included which
get leached into soils into water and
they're hazardous to the people that are
that are disposing of that waste as well
so there's massive environmental
benefits from this move it's only a
small step but it's absolutely a blow
against that
model of the electronics industry built
on proprietary technology and inbuilt
obsolescence so which is driving over
consumption
if the proposal is adopted by the eu
parliament and council it could be law
by 2022 companies will then have two
years to adapt their devices
but consumer electronics giant apple
says the standardization will affect
innovation in two years is not enough
time
the eu says they've given the tech
industry 10 years to come up with a
solution between themselves and they
failed now is the time for legislation
charlie angela al jazeera london